qué pasó exactamente en ese lugar
hola andrés mucho gusto saludar la
audiencia lo que pasó es que es la
tercera jornada seguida de
manifestaciones de los militares
retirados que tienen esta compensación
por su participación en el conflicto
armado y en esta ocasión a diferencia de
las anteriores que ya de por sí le había
sentido una atención en el ambiente una
corporación con marketers y algunos
palos y piedras y se tornó de manera más
violenta
consiguieron romper las costas de hierro
del estacionamiento que está contiguo a
unas oficinas que eran pie después está
el edificio legislativo y al hemiciclo
en donde se iba a hacer presionar a
realizando con funcionarias pero
evidentemente la violencia no lo
permitió los manifestantes alrededor de
el día cientos de cientos de estos que
ocupaban puesto totalmente de una de las
calles el ingreso y
ingresaron temas bueno de las oficinas y
en total cinco carros y vieron a varias
personas entre ellos las tres
periodistas
e ingresaron a hacer destrozos
prácticamente a quemar algunas de las
oficinas pero la policía pues contuvo
los agentes anti no tienen esta protesta
violenta en esta ocasión es algo que no
es ajeno a guatemala pero el año pasado
en noviembre por otras causas y por
otros grupos pero estamos viendo llegar
la segunda ocasión en que se quedan
parte de las confesiones del congreso
emiliano ahora cómo es que lograron
ingresar al congreso
como te mencionaba ellos con palos y
machetes y con la fuerza prácticamente
empujaron las puertas rompieron una zona
gestión directamente el portón grande
que es el que permite el acceso a las
oficinas ha encontrado algunos trabajaba
el congreso y en este momento el
personal del congreso tenía días
trabajadas para impedir que las puertas
se desvanecían y aún así no con
suficiente
se reclamó mucho tanto en redes sociales
como los mismos en la calle no había
presencia necesariamente de la policía
en el momento donde te rompen las
puertas si había policías en otras
oficinas aledañas que no son necesarios
en el palacio legislativo donde ocurre
todo esto pero con la fuerza y pues si
la la protesta la que permitió en el
ingreso de estas personas que entraban a
quemarlo todo el personal que estaba
adentro junto a algunos diputados se
habla de 18 diputados que estaban
todavía dentro de las oficinas
logran resguarde sergio y en algunos
otros sitios que están estas son
muy grandes con diversas oficinas y
pasadizos y pues ninguno había ser
atacados y definitivamente tenían crisis
nerviosa incluso estaba a hablar un
ministro de estado el ministro de
energía y minas
y al final de planta zona y evacuaron
por la otra puerta principal del
concreto del canal que está en la otra
calle para llegaríamos emiliano después
de toda esta situación cuál es el
panorama en este momento se sabe si se
van a tomar nuevas medidas al respecto
el panorama
no es concluyente el hambre es en este
momento
estaría controlado por las fuerzas del
orden hay dos detenidos en este momento
pero el problema de la base
de lo que están pidiendo y las demandas
de los ex militares o militares
retirados es estos aproximadamente 15
mil 500 dólares de recompensa o trabajo
en el conflicto
sabemos que dejó más de 250.000 víctimas
a nivel nacional un millón de
desplazados internos y en su mayoría
según un informe de la onu
estético e histórico una mayoría y
atribuidos al ejército ya los grupos
paramilitares
es algo que no se sabe qué va a pasar el
propio presidente llama t alejandro
giammatei creciente de guatemala durante
la campaña de 2010 imán en la campaña
política que ganó ofreció a este grupo
de militares retirados
este bar ahora esta ley es convención
nacional para beneficiarlos e incluso en
un vídeo que circula de estas de esta
campaña llama te está diciéndoles que el
mismo se va a ir a pararse
a las oficinas y no señora ya mixtas de
que esto suceda fuerte que se
apruebe el congreso